okay so my name is in bar and they work
at Santa Bora and about yeah um about
three or four years ago I was working on
a project with a goal to help doctors to
make better predictions about which
medications we should give to patients
with epilepsy so the idea was to be able
to say when a medication stopped working
why it's not working anymore
and whether we need to increase the dose
of the drug or we need to change the
medication and maybe even be able to
predict which medication would be the
best fit for the specific patient so we
got some pretty decent results for the
first versed of their project and about
this point my one of my advisors which
was the doctor told me you know this is
all really nice but I know doctor you
can't just give them black boxes and
tell them just trust me it just won't
work so we need to be able to understand
why the model says this and that or at
least be able to understand if it's
unconfident of its prediction so deep
learning was already a big high back
then and it was it got some really good
results for computer vision applications
and for speech recognition and people
started applying it to other domains as
well and such a lot of my time on this
project was dealt with engineering
features based on AG I started wondering
whether given enough data we could be
able to use deep learning for this
project as well but without making the
black post problem the black box problem
that we had even bigger so we started
digging into uncertainty in deep
learning and I stumbled across a lot of
papers from the 90s but they didn't find
much going on back then and this was the
situation I'll up until about two years
ago and this is what I'm going to talk
about in this talk so first of all I
want to talk about why we should even
care about uncertainty
so one example is an entire escape
applications like I just described so
from four applications in medicine and
sometimes even in finance we really want
the model to be able to say you know I'm
not confident about this I'm not sure
maybe it's better to give some human
expert to take a second look at this
another example is out of data samples
so if we took a network and we and we
taught it to distinguish between
pictures of a cat and pictures of a dog
and then we said here's a picture of a
monkey what do you think
now sense the network only knows dogs
and cats for sure it's gonna say one of
the two it's gonna play say it's either
a cat or a dog because that's the only
thing that it knows to do but what we
would really want the network to do is
say something like you know I have no
idea I've not seen anything like that
another situation where it could be
useful is for time series prediction so
for instance we could teach a network or
any model to work on time series but we
want it to be able to say this point is
just too far from where I've seen so I'm
not confident about it at all lastly it
could be very useful for us but
practitioners because it gives us a lot
of a new possibilities to debug the
network we could for instance use
uncertainty for for error analysis we
could take a look at their samples that
model got wrong but with very high
confidence and this Ornette these are
examples that we really want to to try
to figure out what went wrong over there
but we could also be interested in in
examples that were okay but with very
low confidence and see if we can boost
the confidence of the models for these
examples okay
so I'm going to talk about uncertainty
types which types of uncertain
uncertainty exists and then I'm going to
give to me give it a really briefing
through an introduction to the Bayesian
learning and I'm gonna talk about it and
your own networks from a probabilistic
point of view and then I'm going to talk
about model uncertainty and data and
sanity so this is a bit of a spoiler for
the first bullet but I'm gonna talk
about those two types of and certain
things and what can we do to to model
those two type of uncertainties and to
incorporate it into the model okay so
some of you at the moment might be
wondering okay what about softmax okay
now first let's talk about which that
one solid is so it's going to talk about
two types of uncertainties the first
type is a lot oricon certainty which
captures the noise that is inherent in
the data and this is further divided
into homoscedastic inferred uncertainty
which is constant for all the data and
for heteroscedastic insanity which says
that some inputs might have noisier and
outputs than other inputs and the the
second type of advanced certainty is
epistemic uncertainty which is
uncertainty about the model itself and
this uncertainty can be explained away
given enough data so it means it if we
see enough data we could be more
confident about the model that we have
in hand and this is not really really
surprising but this is opposed to this
type of insanity that lies within the
data collection process itself so it
doesn't matter how much data we're gonna
collect we won't be able to reduce the
alert the other term and this is the
first time the first type of an
uncertainty so epistemic absurdity is
usually we're gonna talk about
uncertainty in model parameters but we
can also talk about uncertainty in the
model itself or the model structure and
I'm gonna just refer to it as data
uncertainty and model uncertainty okay
so now some of you might be wondering
what about softlocks because softmax
is
function that we give it a vector of
scholars and then it gives us a vector
of probability so we could think that if
we're gonna look about an todayI
probability that the network gave for a
specific output for a specific label and
we say that this level got a very high
probability then it means that the
network is very confident that this is
indeed the true label of the sample okay
but this is in fact not true and the
reason that it's not true is because
what happens when we give the network
the order to work with the softmax we
actually say you have a certain amount
amount of confidence and you have to
divide this confidence between the
different labels so it's kind of pushing
the the networks to say something and
then it might say something like well if
I really have to then I'm gonna bet on
this guy and maybe a little bit of this
guy and this guy but maybe it's not
confident of anything you know maybe if
we could just let it tell us whatever it
do you think it would say you know I
really have no idea so we could get get
a vector with very high probability for
a specific label but the confidence of
the network in this entire vector of
probability would be low okay so we
can't really trust on such box to give
us the certainty that we want luckily we
have basic learning and people have been
using Bayes and learning to get
uncertainty for a very long time now so
I'm going to give a really really brief
introduction just because if somebody is
not familiar with it it's gonna be very
hard to follow the rest of the lecture
so basically learning the tank of
probability as a measure of belief this
means that we have some belief about the
world it could be believable about which
model generated the data or what the
what are the parameters of the model
that generated the data and this belief
is represented using a prior
distribution over for instance the way
and learning in Beijing where it just
means that we updated the belief we
update the prior distribution as more
data comes so when we simmer data the
prior distribution becomes the
prosthetic put the posterior
distribution and we do this update using
best well which is why it's called
Bayesian learning so as we see more data
we can calculate the posterior and then
it's gonna be the likelihood of the data
given the weight times the plyo over the
right and this is all divided by the
distribution over the data okay so this
is based on learning in a nutshell now
let's think about neural networks form a
probabilistic point of view because
usually when we talk about neural
networks we think about it we think of
them as something that want to minimize
some sort of loss function but we could
also think of a neural network from a
probabilistic fault point of view we
could think of a neural network as a
probabilistic model that just tries to
find the distribution of the of Y given
the data and given the weights and this
way if we want to learn the correct
weights what we're gonna do is try to
calculate the maximum likelihood
estimation so it means that we just find
we're just going to find the weights
that maximize the log likelihood that
maximizes the probability of the data
given the weight and since we assume
that all the samples are lighter we can
just break this and then take the same
out and then this is what we're going to
work with okay and alternatively we
could add regularization and then
instead of learning ml M we're gonna
learn maximum a-posteriori we're going
to learn map estimate so this way we're
gonna find W that maximizes the log of
the posterior distribution okay
so you can think about it as sort of
regularization to do the same thing but
with but with adding organization if you
if you look at this two examples
okay this is all the introduction that
we need
now let's talk about modern uncertainty
which is most of the talk is gonna be
about this uncertainty so when we talked
about neural networks for probabilistic
my point of view we still didn't say
anything about uncertainty because we
output the best ways we found we wanted
to look for the ways that are best for
our minimization problem but
alternatively we could sell we are not
confident of the weight so instead of
just outputting one set of weights lets
output an entire probability over the
weight and then we're gonna start with
some pile over the weights and at
learning time we're gonna update this
pile just like we did in Bayesian
learning we're going to update it to the
posterior distribution again over the
weights so we're just gonna calculate
the light lead times the power of the do
it over the weight and this is divided
by the data and it would be actual time
what we want to do is instead of taking
the one set of weights that we have and
calculate the prediction we're gonna
integrate over the entire set of way of
possible weights and for each weight
regard come and calculate the likelihood
times the posterior distribution of this
weight being true given the data that
we've seen okay was that clear
the only problem is that the post area
is intractable for pretty much any any
problem or an interesting problem that
you're gonna work with so it means that
we can't really compute this integral so
I just said something but you can't we
can't work with it
luckily this is not some something
that's unique for neural networks this
is something that you're gonna stumble
across pretty much in any application
that you want to try to work with
Bayesian learning the interrupt ability
of the posterior is just something that
comes back and back to us and this means
that there are also ways to solve it
that are not related to neural networks
and we can use them for our problem so
it's good we can divided their solutions
to two families why one family is
sampling method and the other one is
variational inference
so just to iterate because it's really
important that it's gonna be clear we
have a problem that we have a poster
that is intractable and we want to be
able to use it this posterior somehow
okay so one way would be okay we can't
really calculate the posterior itself
but instead of calculating the posterior
let's sample from it because some
distribution we could sample from even
though we can't really calculate them as
is so let's sample some distribute some
examples from the posterior distribution
and then whatever it is that we are
interested about whatever it is that we
want the posterior to do we would just
calculate this using the samples that we
draw the different the second option to
use would be variational inference and
then this is just saying well we have
one distribution that is interesting but
we can't really calculate it and we have
a difference
so let's instead find a different
distribution that we could use we can do
calculations on and
is as similar as possible to the first
distribution that we interested in I'm
going to talk about it later but I'm
just want to emphasize in terms of bias
and variance which is very common to
talk about in machine learning in
general this method has very high bias
because we choose the variational family
so we already introduced a lot of bias
into the into the method but it has a
lot of wires but this method it doesn't
rely on any assumptions that we'll make
so it doesn't have bias but it has very
high variance and if you're going to
repeat it several times we're going to
get different results so most of the
methods I'm going to talk about are
gonna be from this family and then I'm
going to briefly mention something from
here so just dive a bit deeper into
variational inference in variational
inference we have a target distribution
in our case it's the posterior
distribution and we want to use it but
it's an intractable to as we can't
really calculate the integral of over
this distribution and what we're going
to do is we're gonna approximate it with
a different distribution let's call it Q
which is 4 meter
tractable family and we one find Q that
is as similar as possible to the
posterior distribution and when we talk
about similarity in distribution we
usually talk about KL divergence so kind
of regions you can think about it just
as a measure of how similar one
distribution is to another and this is
just the definition of it okay
now let's see what we what we can do
with it let's assume the dick that kill
the probability that we that we the
reaction probably the probability that
we wanna use is parametrized by theta so
we wanna find that the team in Amaya
minimizes the KL divergence between Q
theta W and the posterior distribution
so this is just opening the definition
using the definition of claim they're
virgins and just opening the posterior
distribution using Bayes law and you can
see that this part over here it's not
dependent not data and not on W so it
it's a constant in our integration
problem so we don't really care about it
so we can remove this and we can break
this entire thing using log laws and
then we can drag the integral into two
parts now if you didn't really follow it
doesn't matter because here comes the
interesting part this is what's
important let's see what we got
the first part here is just the KL
divergence between here Tait and W but
with the prior instance instead of the
posterior so now we're interested in the
curl divergence between Q our variation
of probability and the plyo and this
over here is just the expectation of the
log likelihood with respect to the
variational distribution okay so it's
just the calibration between Q in the
coil and the expectation of log record
with regard to kill so it means that our
minimization problems just becomes some
trade-off between trying to find Q that
fit the data as good as possible finding
Q that gives very high likely to the
data that we see but on the other hand
we want Q to be as simple as possible
and now we say that simple as possible
means that we wanted to be as close as
possible possible to the palais-royal
distribution
okay so this is just another way of
doing regularization in neural networks
this term tries to fit the data and this
term is responsible for the
regularization
and
here is the money
and usually we keep cue something very
very simple it could be some yeah some
gosh sorry starts okay so now that we
have cue
we could just take it and put it in the
integral that we had earlier that we
couldn't compute and now we can compute
it because we found Q that is tractable
okay so this is how we make predictions
that's it and this is work that's been
done by google deepmind in 2015 but the
same ideas were also presented by class
in 2011 and it even goes back to 1993
with the internet VanCamp and last year
it eclipsed there was a workshop about
it about basing deep learning and the
opening talk in this workshop was very
nice talk about the history of Bayesian
and neural networks and it just goes
over the same ideas that goes back to
the 70s so it's really nice to see all
this idea kind of evolve to what we see
today and it's really it's like 40
minutes talk and it's really simple to
follow and I think it's really
recommended if you were interested in
these kind of things and I'm going to
just skip this part okay so now you can
say okay but I don't want to train the
model from scratch I don't want to make
I have my new own Network I'm
comfortable with it I know what good
last function works for me because
they've tested a lot of loss functions
and I've tested I love all sort of
things and I don't want to change my
last function it's their way I could
take the network that they already have
and get uncertainty estimations from it
can I even do that so can I do that well
it turns out that if you use drop out
during training which a lot of
applications do then you actually can
and this is a really nice work that's
been done by a young girl from Cambridge
University and I'm not going to go into
the mathematics here but he says that
if you're gonna if you're gonna choose q
to factorize over different mattresses
WI when you can think of each matrix to
be to correspond to some some layer in
the network and HWI is calculated as a
multiplication between MI and diagonal
over variables Zhi which were each that
IJ is in turns this sample for mandala
distribution with P I then we got
exactly drop out and why is that true
because you can think about that AJ is
something that just chooses if the J
unit in the ice layer in the network is
gonna be dropped and that's exactly what
we do in the drop out so using this way
of interpretation of drop out we can get
a new way to think of Y drop what works
because usually when they talk about
drop out we said that it works because
it adds noise to the challenge to the
trading procedure and then we can avoid
overfitting
but this suggests that robot works
because it approximately integrates over
all other parameters instead of just
taking one set of weights now let's say
that you have a network with drop out
what can you do to get a certainty
estimation a test time instead of just
scaling the parameters like you usually
do with the drop out you're gonna do
exactly what you do it training time
you're gonna take you're gonna do a drop
out you gotta take random units choose
units at window and remove them from the
network and then you're gonna get a bad
prediction and you're gonna repeat this
procedure 80 times and you're gonna get
a sample of D predictions you can
calculate the mean of this sample and
this is going to be the prediction and
the virus of the sample is gonna be the
uncertainty estimation
yes so a lot of a lot of the criticism
about all of the things I'm going to
talk about is that it's really really
high it's really hard to do it when you
have application that needs to be very
online that need to be very to work very
fast and that's true and that's a lot of
the problems with those and with those
things but still I think for at least
for a practitioners when they try to
debug your model you could use it even
if you can't really use it at a test
time and sound occasions don't need to
work that fast and you can say okay I'm
okay I would be with being a bit slower
but being more reliable so not
necessarily because no one could go and
tease you that the last wet is the best
okay you can think about it as we need
the optimization then you start to work
your way through the last and until you
get to a specific area and this is our
an area that is good for you but it's
not as a sure it's not it's not
guaranteed at the last point that you're
gonna get in this year area is the best
maybe you want to get yeah but even not
in terms of optic of global versus local
minimum some people says that maybe you
want to get some estimation of the
entire area that is good for you and not
just one point from it and the
relationship
yeah actually
where
what I mean you're looking for the
uncertainty of the output of the model
yeah the more you reduce to increase the
probability of jump out yeah then it's
gonna be more yeah so the more you the
more you take more and more in a unit a
couple then you're gonna get the virus
is gonna get bigger but this is
something that's true for dropping in
general so how do you know I still don't
understand the question of scaling yeah
so he said well you sell let's take
dropout and use this thing to calculate
uncertainty but if you take dropout with
higher if you take dropout with higher
light then you're gonna get more virus
and then you're probably gonna get less
less than certain model did I understand
it correctly
okay so I'm gonna think about it you
come back to
drawn to you
the result
I think what it means by that is that
you want to take the model that you have
which you chose which you chose to drop
out not not as a way to measure
uncertainty but as a way to optimize
your model and that it's usually like
1.5 which is what usually people thought
and gonna get this network and you want
to to try to assess the the confidence
of this model you don't want to choose
the two apart for this okay so given
that you already have a network that was
trained enjoy but you could use it this
is a nice example the tears hey you can
sit on his blood we're trying a very
small network to do drop or calculate a
two-week dropout and it's supposed to
fit the location problem and in the blue
you could see the mean of the sample and
this is one sample and the shaded area
is the confidence so you can see that
when we have more data points our
confidence is it's better okay because
this is the standard deviations the
standard deviation is smaller which
means that our confidence is larger and
he has a really nice demonstration in
the side where you can add more points
and you see how this effects the how
this affects the uncertainty so it's
really nice to play with it if you want
okay this was about variational
inference method and now I want to talk
briefly about Markov chain about modern
sampling methods and one of the most
successful most famous sampling method
is Markov chain Monte Carlo where you
would construct a Markov chain where the
desired probability the desired
distribution that you have in mind
the distribution that it should you try
to sample from is the equitable
distribution of mass of this Markov
chain so it means that we have some
random process
that you get samples from and as we get
as we draw more samples and as we update
the model we get samples that form the
distribution that we wanted so in this
way we mean that we're gonna use them
CMC to get samples from the supposed to
a distribution and then we're gonna get
those samples and we're gonna and we're
gonna use them so we have samples of
weights and we're gonna use each weight
to get with a channel we're gonna just
average the predictions from the
different samples the test time and
again you might think okay said what
this have to do with deep learning it
sounds really different than everything
that we're doing de planning but as it
turns out and this is a really cool
paper that if you just just by adding
noise to the parameter update you get
something that approximate F CMC
algorithm so let me just be clear this
is standard STD for map estimate so we
get it we take a started an STD we take
the network that we have and all we need
to do is at the update step we're gonna
add some noise and by adding the noise
it's guaranteed the Terra is gonna it's
gonna converge to the posterior
distribution and that's really cool
cause it means that we can just sample
from the final distribution that we have
or we could just take weight from this
the last phase of the training and we
could use them to make predictions and
just do model everything as we did
before okay so this was about more than
a certainty that was the main part of
the talk
so they're they they said she should
scale the noise as you as you progress
with the step so the the largest step
you need to make the noise a bit smaller
I just didn't want to get it but they
had it's in the paper so you could just
read okay
so data a certainty sometimes we don't
want to just calculate that certainty in
the model we want to we want to capture
and strategy that we have in the data so
sometimes for example our labels might
be might be noisy so this is a work by
our Becker from byline University and
what they said is let's assume the true
level
I'll pass through noise channel with
other parameters and all it is is add
add an extra noise layer to the networks
we take a like your network and you just
add another layer which needs to capture
the name in the noise and then let's
look at the likelihood what it becomes
so the probability of the syn label the
dilemma that we see to be J given X W in
theta which is the parameter of the
night it's gonna be a sum of 1 over K
where K is the number of labels that we
have of the probability of the sea level
to be J given that the true level is y
so we have a true level but we also know
say so maybe the level that we see in
the data is gonna be different so the
probability of the say that say level to
be J given the true level is y and this
is all multiplied by the probability of
Y given x value and this is now the
likely so we just gonna put it in the
locker by fluid model and we
learn just as we do regularly yeah the
level that we see from the data
why okay why is the latent parameter
why is delay the true level so we
assumed it the actual label for every
sample but for some samples the true
level got started using nice and so we
see that instead of Y okay but instead
instead we can say for instance for the
regression problem let's just try to
learn the noise itself I try to learn
the parameter of the noise so the noise
here is modeled by Sigma and then we're
gonna say we're gonna assume that the
noise is gonna be different for each
point for each set point so we're
talking about heteroscedastic noise and
we're just gonna take the regular update
equation and we're gonna add nice to it
we're gonna use the noise and this means
that the network not up is not
outputting just one neuron we're gonna
output two neurons one for the mean
which means the predicted label and one
for the violence one for the standard
deviation and you could also combine
those two you could combine chop out
with in order to measure the modern
Saturday and you could combine it with
for instance adding noise output to
predict the variance to predict the data
certainly okay so this was an overview
overview of what methods you have in
general to capture uncertainty both
model uncertainty in their authority and
I'm gonna talk very shortly about what
we do with those things in tabouleh so
Tabora
is a discovery pot platform
means that it means that we have some
user that is reading a specific article
and we wanna try to estimate what is the
best article to give the specific user
in this specific specific time
so given a user and a context we want to
find the best article or the best
advertise to give to the user and this
is model as a click-through rate
estimation problem so we want to
estimate the city of each item that we
can give the user and then we're gonna
we want to choose the items that have
the highest CTR which means that they
have the highest probability of the user
to click on those items okay so instead
of just outputting the city out from the
model we could output out also the
standard deviation and this allows us to
do all sort of things so each
recommendation system has the built in
problem of trade-off in between
exploration and exploitation explanation
means that you wanna collect new
information about the world so for
instance they get a new item and I've
never seen this item so I don't know
anything about it I could know things
like the text or the image of these
items but they know nothing about which
type of users like this items which type
of context works best for this item so
if we don't have this information I want
to start showing this item to people to
different people different context in
order to have the same information about
this item and this is called exploration
exploitation just means okay I have a
bunch of items that I know things about
and I wanna get in and I wanna give the
best items that I can given what I know
and this is already also a trade-off
that is very common in enforcement
learning when you want to trade up
between exploration of the agent and
explain
exploitation between the agents
exploring it its environment
and between the agent trying to choose
the actions that that maximizes its
payoff so once we have the standard
deviation we could use it in order to
make decisions about this trade-off we
could for instance say well this item
has a very very high standard deviation
so this means that we'd done it means
that we don't know a lot about it so
maybe we'll want to start showing it
more to collect more information about
this item even if it doesn't get a very
high CTR because we want to try to
figure out what's going on here but
items with very low City aren't very low
as standard deviations
maybe we just we just don't want to show
it another thing we could do is
debugging on our network so we could ask
ourselves are we modeling the right
things we usually talk about deep
learning and we say okay so now we don't
need to do feature engineering anymore
how lucky us but at least that
recommendation aging and also some other
domains Wescott in this domain you you
don't you didn't really get rid of the
feature engineer pants
you still need to try to find the best
features and try to find best
presentations for different aspects of
the data so for instance if we have a
sub Network or some model that takes the
title of an article and make a
presentation of it for the other model
to use and we want to ask ourselves is
this representation good so we could use
some visualization stuff to look about
it but we could also look at the
standard deviation and we could say
let's start taking off words from the
title and let's see what happens to the
standard deviation what happens to the
modern uncertainty is read
of some of the some of the information
that we have in the title and if the
information is data in the title is very
important and we model it in a good way
then it means that as we remove more
words our uncertainty the what the
uncertainty of the mother should
increase but if we see that we can
remove words and nothing happens to them
certainty then it means that either the
information in the title is not
important at all or it means that we
don't know other things right and you
cannot you could also think about it as
a way to do feature selection you can
think about it let's let's see which
features they can remove and affect the
the confidence of the model in a very
serious way so not just looking at the
performance of the one after the model
but also looking at the confidence of
the model and if we remove removed
features and the model has become very
and not confident then it means that
this feature is very important for the
model one last thing that I'm going to
mention is in recommendation yeah
so that's sort of its classic feature
selection it's very heavy so you don't
really want to do it but it's just
another way to think about the same
problem you could say let's let's not
use this feature in the Train and see
what happens and now we could we could
not use a different feature and see what
happens and this is a way for us to
start understand if a feature that we
thought is important is indeed important
so one last thing is in recommendation
engines you have a problem of noisy
labels which is built-in it doesn't even
it's not even a thing of how you collect
the data because okay so if somebody
clicked on something then I know that
it's probably interesting for him but
let's say that I showed a user I
presented it with a specific item and
then he didn't click what can I know
about it is did is this indeed a
negative label I don't know because
maybe he didn't click because he just
wasn't in the mood now maybe in some
other context would be okay
maybe they didn't clear because it just
didn't see it it didn't it didn't go to
this part of the page or he just didn't
just ignored it maybe didn't click
because it's really interesting for him
but he doesn't have time no so all the
negative labels are very very noisy and
we could think about modeling this noise
and instead of trying to to optimize the
using for instance maximum likelihood
let's say we have a distribution offered
over the labels and we have a
distribution that the network is
outputting and then let's try to
optimize using KL divergence let's find
try to to match those two distribution
so this is just something we're playing
it it didn't give a very good result so
far which is just an idea okay so I
think yeah that's all I wanted to talk
about but if you're interested in in
this topic
this is pretty much the book that I
always recommend everybody just ask me
anything about the book in machine
learning it's a really really good book
because it talks about all sorts of
models from probabilistic point of view
and you don't really see this this point
of view very often you could get through
and like I think I did about five
criticisms in machine learning in the
university without seeing this point of
view for the same model that I've
already learned so it's really
interesting and also it's very very
Bayesian so it's it has good
introduction for based on learning and
for other things that are led to it and
it's very well written and the Knicks
last year and I think even the year
before had a workshop about dating
learning and it had a base and deep
learning and it had some talks with
titles like it's basically deep learning
the best thing in the world so you
definitely want to see it and you're in
God which I mentioned all across the the
talk because it did it really a lot of
work on the subject so he has some blog
posts which are really nice they are
written well sort of like academic
papers so you need to bear this in mind
and here within an entire thesis on the
subject and I think it writes really
good so you should read it and this is
all bunch of papers that I briefly
mentioned the reading the talk so you're
gonna get the presentation I think so if
you if something was interesting to you
you can just look at it and that's it
okay so just one last thing that I want
to mentioned and that I want to mention
is that data hack is hackathon about
data science and machine learning we've
is doing the wood thing again it's gonna
take place in October 25 to 27 it's it
was a really nice event in the last
couple of years I think and we hope that
last that the next event is going to be
nicer so the registration is opening
tomorrow and I really hope to see there
that's it
[Applause]